zumindest ein Thema was überhaupt nicht
funktioniert heute war großer warntag um
11 Uhr sollten überall diese regenschein
wann ich überall der Fall und sie sagen
zum Glück war das nur eine Probe absolut
wir haben im Katastrophenschutz gesehen
heute der warntag in vielen
Bundesländern hat es nicht geklappt mit
den Warnungen in manchen besser in
Berlin beispielsweise keine einzige
Sirene hat aufgehört weil eben nur 28
400 Standorten besetzt waren aber die 28
waren nicht angeschlossen dann haben wir
das Problem dass natürlich nicht nur die
Warnung selber problematisch ist sondern
es muss auch davor was passieren die
Selbsthilfe Fähigkeiten in der
Bevölkerung muss hergestellt werden und
auch nach einer Warnung muss eine
Katastrophe bewältigt werden und auch da
liegt der Hase im Pfeffer denn die
Behörden sind auf Katastrophen nicht
mehr vorbereitet wir haben das im Alter
gesehen wir sehen das immer wieder
gerade in den großen Städten ist die
Koordination mangelhaft und wir können
wirklich darf das hier nur mal betonen
dass das diesmal noch keine echte
Katastrophe war denn dann wird's
wirklich haarig für Deutschland ich will
nicht mit seiner schlechten Nachricht
aus der Sendung gehen sie müssen uns
immer noch nachliefern was passieren
muss wann wird es klappen doch nicht
erst in Berlin haben sie glaube ich
gesagt 2024 bitte sagen sie dass das
nicht sein kann
ja das ist jetzt sehr schwierig also ich
sag mal eine Minute habe ich auf dem
organer gesagt
woran es liegt ja wir haben einen Senat
der sich um die Prioritäten nicht
kümmert und es braucht eine Politik die
anfängt sich damit zu beschäftigen wie
wir die Probleme in den Griff bekommen
FDP hat ein ganz klaren Vorschlag
gemacht diese organisierte
Verantwortungslosigkeit die wir
beispielsweise in Berlin haben einen
Sinn hat er sagt die Bezirke sind schuld
das in Katastrophenschutz nichts
passiert
nein da muss man eine ganz radikale
Reform machen wir müssen in Berlin
beispielsweise zu einer einstufigen
Verwaltung kommen wo diese elenden
Bezirksämter wegkommen wo man einfach
sagt es gibt auch einen der am Ende
verantwortlich ist oder eine die am Ende
verantwortlich ist die verantwortlich
handelt und Verantwortung auch übernimmt
grundsätzliches Problem gerade im
Katastrophenschutz ganz ganz wichtig
dass da in Deutschland was passiert weil
unsere Katastrophenschutzbehörden haben
30 Jahre jetzt Friedensdividende und so
weiter leider aufgebraucht viel zu wenig
Aufmerksamkeit alles zusammen
wenn wir ein Blackout haben dann wird es
auch mit der Warnung schwierig weil die
Sirenen ja nicht funktioniert ja
ich hatte die eigentlich angezündet für
die Opfer aber wahrscheinlich zünde ich
die gerade für unser Land an weil es
wird bald dunkel werden und wenn man das
hört ganz ehrlich für diesen Berliner
Senat und diese Versagen hilft keine
Kerze mehr da helfen nur Neuwahlen und
ich hoffe dass wir in einem Ernstfall
alle geschützt sind aber wir sollten mal
bei den Bürgern anfangen langsam
aufzuschreiben und zu sagen bis hier und
nicht weiter das ist doch nicht wirklich
unser Land was ihr abläuft Unfähigkeit
hoch 10